the rhine is shrinking shrinking so much
it now has a beach
germany's commercial artery carries
every cargo imaginable steel fuel
chemicals as far as the north sea but at
the busy port town of koblenz the barges
are now leaving three quarters empty
on the wall
there are different colors and that's
normal water level
now it's decreased very much they need
more ships for the same cargo that means
the ships are more expensive and
the
costs per tonne
are
increasing
the pinch point is reached downstream at
kaub some large barges can no longer
pass here
this isn't the bank of the river iron
that i'm standing on it's the bed of the
river rhine so much has the water
receded over the last couple of months
because of the lack of rainfall
and the ships that you can see passing
behind me would normally have about two
meters of water beneath them so that
that's about that much water but at the
minute
some parts have got as little as this
much water 40 centimeters below the
boats as they pass
and the land the rhine ribbons through
is equally parched for 30 years reinhoyt
honor has watched his vineyard slowly
desiccate he's noticed the insects and
the weeds changing he last saw rain on
june 6th
the steps that they are taking to try to
combat the hot weather on this vineyard
are quite extraordinary they're pumping
30 000 liters of water onto these young
vines every single day
they're also allowing the leaves to grow
bigger and to shelter
the grapes below they've got two planes
and two pilots on standby for the whole
of the summer in case there should be a
hailstorm which would damage the grapes
it's not just the wine harvested threat
his neighbors have lost a third of their
corn it's just stopped growing
we know that in any language
the rhine may for now still be teeming
with life
but many germans are questioning for how
much longer they will be able to rely
upon it as an economic lifeline